to use the demo option you have to go to
server te pile that info here under the
transcriptomics section you will have an
arrow that you can open up and see
several projects that are available as
demo in transcriptomics one we use the
PE X project as an example you click on
this link and now you can build a demo
pipeline by clicking on start your
initializing the first step you can read
a little bit about RNA seek and the
logic of how different sections and
different methods are applied to the
data that we uploaded for you here you
can also check the input files the input
files include links svl if you download
this file you'll be able to open it in
any text format and then see the links
to the files that are already stored on
the server now you have several options
you can explore the different sections
like pre-processing mapping on genome as
a form construction mapping on
transcripts and quantification of
expression levels let's build a pipeline
that includes pre-processing steps like
trim Ematic PCR clean and then we have
several options for mapping we can
either map on the genome with bowtie to
G and after mapping on genome we can
visualize the mapped reads you can
always go back by right-clicking on your
previous selection you will get a pop-up
where you can click on OK the other
option is to use mapping on transcripts
with bowtie 2 T by clicking here you
will be able to map on the GTF file
reference transcripts and not the full
genome if you click on OK you will be
able to quantify the expression levels
using our sin
RSM expression table clicking on a semi
expression table you will also see what
is your output and the output is the
table of expression
click on ok now you have the option to
do differential gene expression analysis
this is covered in transcriptomics too
so for now we can end this pipeline by
clicking on end you can read more about
these different sections and the
different pipelines available by going
to the transcriptomics section now you
get download output files here you have
several outputs you can get all of the
outputs as a zip file or download
individual ones either filtered or
non-filtered expression of genes
isoforms and also mapping statistics for
mapping on the transcriptome let's take
a look at the mapped our same expression
genes F began when the file is
downloaded we can find it in the
downloads folder this file could be
opened in Excel or any kind of table
manipulation software inside we see that
we have a number of different samples
are available in this table some of them
are marked as ers that stands for
estrogen receptor-positive and some of
them stand for TN or triple negative in
the rows we will be able to see
different types of genes in as G stands
for human genes but we'll also find in
as mus or genes that come from the mouse
genome we can create another demo
pipeline using a different method for
example we can use Sailfish that will
map our data using a database it will
not require a reference genome and GTF
file now you get different types of
outputs where you have fpkm read count
ante p.m. for both genes and isoforms
let's take a look at what's inside
as you can see the names of the columns
stayed the same however here all of a
sudden we have a lot of genes that have
zero expression if we scroll to the top
of this table you will see because it's
called filtered you won't see any genes
that have zero expression across all
samples yuma Sailfish however you get a
lot of those genes so you can see here a
lot more genes if you scroll down to the
bottom so you get a total of ninety six
thousand six hundred and ninety eight
genes as opposed to here we only have
three thousand three hundred and eleven
genes what other options do we have in
this demo let's take a look at some of
the visualization for example we can
visualize without pre-processing using
both i2g and then clicking on the
visualization button the visualization
button will use the j browse genome
browser that will show us how the reads
align to the reference genome you can
see that now I selected visualization
only on the human genome not the mouse
genome let's click on visualization in
the visualization section I'll be able
to see all of my samples where I can
select whether I want to look at
coverage and snip or alignment and I can
compare how reads from different samples
align to the reference genome remember
this is only the human genome here I
will have different chromosomes that I
can select and I can also search for
different genes right here
you will see here the actual gene the
exons are my marked by red
if there are no reads that map to this
region I won't be able to see anything
below however here I can navigate and
zoom in or zoom out to see the
information about the genes and about
the reads that I have the far the
farther I scroll out the more I can
easily navigate and see the reads this
is an educational data set so we
actually won't see that many reads
aligned but in some portions there will
be more if I want to zoom in I can go
right here and zoom in to see where the
reads are aligned to so these reads are
aligned to these exons if I expand this
further I will also be able to see the
reference on the genome you see it says
here zoom in to see sequence so you can
clearly see that the reads are aligned
but there's not that many reads in most
of them for example you can see that all
the ER estrogen receptor-positive don't
have that many reads they're under 3 to
5 in FP cam but here sorry this is not
these are raw counts and not if P cam
they're not normalized for anything
however here in the triple negative you
can see that I have a lot more reads it
goes all the way up to 70 the abundant
areas fall on exons like here if i zoom
in further I will be able to also see
the reference sequence of the genome
other pipelines can be built I can also
look at variation that comes as a result
of different pre-processing different
types of mapping as well as different
types of quantification strategies if I
add if I had pre-processing steps I'll
be able to use for example high cell two
and then after I've added high satu I
can use HT seek in this video we saw how
we can create different demo pipelines
and get the expression data quickly by
looking at different projects in the RNA
seek section if we go back to areas of
analysis again you can open the section
by clicking on this arrow and selecting
a number of different projects that you
can practice this with